(CRUNCHING)
HIGHEST GIRL: Come
on, slow poke! Come on!
Don't lean forward!
(BOTH LAUGHING)
(SHARK THEME PLAYING)
MAN: Come on, Overman.
Give us a break, will you?
Look at the clown
in the jockey shorts!
Kelly, come on.
Pay attention.
Hey. Girls!
Do it like this! (SHRIEKING)
MAN: Damn it, Kelly!
Do the job!
Next time we're goin' all
the way into the lagoon.
The lagoon is my favorite!
(LAUGHING)
Damn boat.
I flooded the...
(SPUTTERING)
Damn boat!
GIRL: Come on, Richie.
I got a date tonight!
RICHIE: Come on, baby.
(ENGINE STARTING)
Okay, guys, here we go.
MAN: Oh! That's right. Good.
WOMAN: You've been chosen
as teammates for your neatness,
courtesy toward others and
above all, your Southern grace.
We enforce
our dress code here,
so keep your hair
and nails trimmed.
And, please,
don't alter your costumes.
Once you've been fitted with
your SeaWorld guide apparel,
the shorts are short enough.
(GIRL GIGGLING)
Show any cheek and you'll
be back shovelin' French fries.
(GIRLS GIGGLING)
Now, let's continue with our welcome
speech again. All together now.
ALL: Welcome to SeaWorld,
the world's largest
marine life park.
Above and below the surface of
our unique Undersea Kingdom...
MAN: The park officially
opens on Saturday.
All this week has been, and
continues to be, preview week,
during which family and friends
attend SeaWorld as our guests.
This is the Undersea Kingdom,
four years under construction,
at a cost of more than $34 million.
Four pressurized viewing
tunnels radiate out into the lagoon.
There's the Sunken Spanish
Galleon, Jonah's Marine Fun House,
the Deepwater Coral Forest, all
connected to the hub, Central Control.
And a deluxe restaurant
and cocktail lounge,
all 40 feet
below the surface.
The whole complex is built
in our manmade lagoon,
which is connected to the open
ocean by a deep water channel.
The new additions to SeaWorld
are the brainchild
of entrepreneur
Calvin Bouchard.
KELLY: Hi, guys!
GIRL: Now you can
close the gate.
(GATE MOTOR WHIRRING)
(THUDDING)
(GATE MOTOR STOPS WHIRRING)
MAN: Jesus!
Overman, I thought you said
those tracks were secure.
Hey guys, I welded
the damn thing myself.
WORKER 1: Something's
hung the gate up.
WORKER 2: Better get Mike Brody
out here. Boy, is he gonna be pissed.
Wham!
MAN: Here's the lagoon.
Set up for the turn.
PR MAN: I call your attention
to the SeaWorld skiers,
who are about to
enter the lagoon
in a preview of the
opening day ceremonies.
(REPORTERS TALKING
INDISTINCTLY)
Here come
my pride and joy.
(LAUGHING TRIUMPHANTLY)
FEMALE REPORTER: Are we gonna
get a chance to talk to Mr. Bouchard?
Beautiful. Just beautiful!
GIRL SKIER: Hi!
(LAUGHING)
PR MAN: We would, however, like
to avoid references to his colorful past.
(REPORTERS LAUGHING)
WOMAN: Did the Undersea
Kingdom really cost $30 million?
Aren't those kids great?
(LAUGHING)
Mr. Bouchard, is there anything
special goin' on openin' day?
Well, this afternoon,
at the main gate,
we'll be pleased
to announce
the welcomin' of
Mr. Philip FitzRoyce.
Oh, really? Is that true?
(LAUGHING EXCITEDLY)
No lie, boys and girls. He gonna be
here. Now, we got drinks at the bar.
They free. Come on,
follow me.
(REPORTERS LAUGHING)
Overman,
what's it look like?
It's off the track.
How'd that happen?
I can't tell,
but she is jammed.
Just wouldn't
close, Mike.
OVERMAN: Now what
are we gonna do?
Oh, boy.
MAN: Somethin' knocked the
son-of-a-bitch right off the track.
Well, look. Just secure
the damn gate, all right?
Think you can handle that?
On overtime, maybe.
Straight time maybe?
You got enough overtime.
Your party.
You buy the beer, Brody.
Well, look,
you're in charge.
See you guys later. I got
more important things to do.
No overtime.
Okay. See you, Mike.
(SHOUTING)
No overtime!
ALL: (SHOUTING)
(ALL LAUGHING)
(DOLPHINS CLICKING)
(CLICKING LOUDLY)
(CLICKING CONTINUING)
Hi, Mike.
Hey.
Oh. Ah. Hey, Dan.
Havin' gate problems?
The dolphins tried
to open them again.
Where's the boss?
Up
Thanks.
LIZ: Come on, Cindy.
Come on, Sandy. Come on.
Hey, Liz.
Hey. Come on.
It's the boss hard hat.
Where's your boots?
I only wear 'em to bed
and in the shower.
Where's Kay?
She's down that way.
Yee-hah!
Ride 'em, cowgirl.
Hi, Mike!
Hey!
I'll be with you
in a minute, darlin'.
All right.
Use your spurs.
Hey, Liz!
Good boy. That was nice!
Hey. Hey!
Liz, he did that great.
I don't wanna do it again.
Do me a favor.
Put Cindy and Sandy in the lagoon
for a run, okay? They're getting fat.
Okay.
How you doin'?
Great.
Hey, you. Come here.
(SHAMU SQUEAKING)
Come here, kiddo.
That's the feeding place.
Is this whale
house-broken yet?
Nope.
Then he can't
come to dinner.
You takin' me to dinner?
Yeah, soon as we
pick up my brother.
When's Sean coming?
He's on a park shuttle. We're
gonna meet him at the main gate.
DAN: Hey, Kathy.
Cindy and Sandy
don't wanna go.
What, am I gonna lose you
to a couple of neurotic fish?
Mammals.
Mammals. Mammals.
DAN: Something seems
to be bugging 'em.
Well, listen.
It's their play time.
If they don't want it, they'll be
beggin' us tomorrow. Put 'em up.
You got it.
I'm begging you tonight.
You don't have to beg.
So take me to dinner!
All right. Let's try sushi.
Mike!
I'll change.
Come here.
Who's a good boy?
Are you a good boy?
Yes, you're a good boy.
And you get a fish.
CALVIN: Ladies and
gentlemen, here he is now.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Mr. Philip FitzRoyce, with a capital R
is here to film us, meet our
resident day scientific staff.
(BOTH LAUGHING)
Hey, what's this?
Oh, no.
Philip the Great.
I am, of course, able to
combine business with pleasure,
which, they tell me, is the
secret to a long and happy life.
What, FitzRoyce?
Mmm.
Sure is.
And now, ladies and gentlemen, any further
questions, in the bar, if you please.
For the first one
who buys one, right?
Look at Calvin. Best of
buddies. Ah, best of friends.
MIKE: A regular
Barnum and Bailey.
KAY: I'm sure they'll
be very happy together.
Perfect.
Mmm-hmm.
Into the Undersea
Kingdom they go.
(BOTH CHUCKLING)
Hey, Mikey!
Hey. Hey! Hey!
Oh!
How you doin'?
All right!
My brother, the cowboy.
Hey! Hug me, huh?
Oh, Okay.
Hey.
(KAY SHRIEKING)
You put on weight, you need
a shave and you're too tall.
Well, two out of three
I can fix.
(LAUGHING) Get that
gear and let's go. Come on.
So, nice boots.
Thanks! Aw, gee.
I can't even believe
I did that.
How'd you do on your finals?
Great. A gentleman's "C,"
an incomplete, but I aced Phys. Ed.
KAY: A real Einstein.
Glad you're here,
buddy.
(FAINT SQUEALING)
(GASPS)
(MUFFLED SCREAMS)
(THUDDING)
(PEOPLE TALKING INDISTINCTLY)
There you go, Charlene.
MAN 1: Shelby showed up yet?
MAN 2: Haven't seen him.
WOMAN: What are they doing?
MAN: Kelly's really
gettin' this one down.
WOMAN: See that big guy over there?
He gets knocked on his ass every night.
(WOMAN LAUGHING)
All right, Charlene.
All right!
Here, let me help you out.
Work with me, work with me.
Let's go.
There we go.
Wait. One more.
Hey, Mike.
All right. Yeah?
Is Shelby workin' overtime?
Not on my say-so. He was supposed
to knock off with the rest of the guys.
Have you met
my kid brother?
If he's messin' around with that
little bitch down at the souvenir stand,
it's gonna be his ass.
You tell him.
(CLEARING THROAT)
Charlene, I'm not his mother.
You're his boss.
Yeah, ask Woodbury, okay?
MAN: Come on, Kelly.
You can do it!
Hey, they're
playing stand-off.
Uh-oh.
My brother considers himself to be
the stand-off champion of New England.
And the western states.
Go get 'em.
(GROWLING)
(WHOOPING)
MAN: Hey, I wasn't ready!
I tell you,
it's a game of balance.
I told you
he'd fall on his ass.
MAN: Hey, who's this guy?
This is for beers.
You buyin'?
Ready?
Mm-hmm.
(PEOPLE WHOOPING)
(WOMAN LAUGHING)
My fly's open. (CHUCKLING)
(PEOPLE GASPING)
No fair!
MAN: Whoo!
Well, it's, uh,
not only a game of balance,
it's a game of deception.
Come on, I'll buy you two
for the one you owe me.
Okay.
All right.
MAN: All right.
GIRL: See you later, Kelly.
Hey, I want you. Come on,
right now! Let's go.
Kathryn, Mike.
MIKE: Hi.
You know each other?
I see my brother
nailed you, eh?
Your brother? Yeah,
believe it or not.
If he wouldn't have pulled that old
crotch trick, he never would have won.
That's his best move.
Runs in the family.
Well, it worked.
What are we drinkin'?
Champagne of
the working classes.
Beer. And you
owe me a couple.
That's right.
Comin' up.
Two beers. So, you
work at the park, huh?
Mmm-hmm.
I'm a water skier.
Oh.
(LAUGHING)
Your brother's cute.
Yeah. Him and Kathryn have, uh,
been together for a year and a half.
How about you?
Desperately unattached.
Lonely, confused.
Generous and loving to
a fault. It's all in my eyes.
MAN 1: (WHISPERING) Come On.
MAN 2: (WHISPERING) Okay.
We'll cop a lot of
good stuff tonight.
I've got the tanks.
Shh!
Is the van okay here?
Yes, it's okay.
We're off SeaWorld property.
Nobody uses this road.
Shh!
Yeah.
All right.
Climb over the fence, and
take it easy with the raft.
(CLATTERING)
Damn it!
You asshole.
Now we gotta drag it all
the way down to the water!
Ready to go?
Okay. Who's payin'?
Ah.
Watch out. Snakes.
Oh, come on.
Don't bullshit me.
Chicken, huh?
(CROAKING)
(MAN GASPS)
All right, steady.
Steady.
Got it.
Okay. Here we go.
Come on, paddle!
I am.
Let's go out to the center.
I sure hope
this is worth it.
(LAUGHING)
(MIKE GROANING)
Hey, Kelly,
is this your car?
Sure is.
Hey. Get off of there!
(GROANING)
You wanna take a walk? Yeah.
Hey, what about
baby brother?
Aww! Aww!
Little baby brother.
Kelly, can you give him a ride
home, or shall I call his mommy?
Nah, if he'll come quietly.
No way. I scream and shout.
Oh, God, it stinks out
here. Let's get away!
See ya.
Hey, let's go swimming.
No, I hate the ocean.
Aww! Hey, I've got
a better idea.
Like lagoons?
Lagoons?
Lagoons.
(LAUGHING)
(ENGINE STARTING)
Oh. How come Sean
doesn't visit more?
He hates the water.
What?
Yeah. Remember that shark attack I
told you about when we were kids in Amity?
Well, that's why he goes
to school in Colorado.
If our parents didn't live on an
island, I don't think he'd ever get wet.
(LAUGHING)
My dad, he's the same way.
God, I love this place.
I hated it when
we first came here.
What's the matter?
Did you get a telephone call?
Venezuela?
Guess I'm gonna have to
start learning Spanish.
(EXHALING) Ooh, baby.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's wonderful.
Oh, shit.
Reality.
How long?
Just a short
year and a half.
I'd love you to come,
you know.
Yeah.
But what about the six
months I've got left here
and the job opening up
at the Scripps Institute?
What about that? Huh?
Simple. Just give up
your life and follow me.
(LAUGHING)
Oh, I'm happy
for you. I am.
I know you are.
What are we gonna do?
A-ha.
Mm-hmm.
(BOTH CHUCKLING)
(GRUNTING)
(LAUGHING)
(CHUCKLING)
Come on.
Oh, I don't go in the water.
You don't swim?
Not even with friends?
Oh, uh, I swim.
I just, uh, I... I...
(SIGHING) It's something
that happened when I was a kid.
I just, I don't go in the water.
(LAUGHING AWKWARDLY)
I bet I can overcome
your childhood fears.
I bet you can.
Come on.
My boots!
Kick 'em off, cowboy.
Kelly!
Come on in, Sean.
It's fun.
Come on.
Here?
Yeah, okay.
Somewhere down there
is the best coral.
A guy in Miami will give us
$200 for the good stuff.
Put it in the basket.
I'll pull it up.
(KELLY LAUGHING IN DISTANCE)
Come on, hurry, Randy.
KAY: I love this park
at night. It's so deserted.
MIKE: Yeah. So quiet.
Wait a second.
Isn't that Kelly's car?
Stop, stop, stop.
Shh! Wait a second.
Stop.
Shh.
(GIGGLING)
I don't believe it.
She got him in the water.
Never underestimate
the power, huh?
Attention. You, in the water. You
are trespassing on SeaWorld property.
Come out of the water with your
hands raised high above your head.
I'm okay.
My brother works here.
Uh, I'm Kelly Ann Bukowski,
from the ski team.
You turkeys have any ID?
Wait a minute.
Mike? Kay?
Brother?
Mr. Bullhorn sees all,
knows all!
Dead is what you are!
You keep your hands
to yourself, young m...
(KELLY SCREECHING)
Here, take this.
MIKE: Yell for mother!
(MIKE AND SEAN SHOUTING
IN THE DISTANCE)
Finish up down there,
damn it!
Come on, Randy.
We gotta get out of here!
(MUFFLED THUD)
Now what?
Ow!
(SHOUTING)
KELLY: Mike!
(GIRLS SCREECHING)
(GIRLS YELLING)
KAY: You cheater!
(SCREAMING)
SEAN: That's what
you are! Dead!
Some guys can sleep in
in the morning.
Some of us have to be at
work early. Good morning.
Some of us don't have to baby-sit
a park full of slugs and fishes either.
Yes, we just live like slugs and
fishes. Good morning, Maggie.
The dog does not eat on
the counter. (GROANING)
I put your wet clothes
in the dryer, sweetie.
Thanks.
Mmm. What are we eating?
Mmm. Thank you.
Hey, is this my beeper
or your beeper?
I don't know.
I'll use this beeper.
Use that beeper.
Talk to you later.
I'll have my beeper
beep your beeper.
beep your beeper back.
Bye.
See you later.
Aye.
Coffee?
Just throw it in my eyes,
it'll work faster.
Yeah, well that's what happens
when you stay up all night
workin' out your
childhood phobias.
That's right. Make fun
of your baby brother.
But I was this close to
doing it in the water last night,
and that's a first.
This close, huh?
Shut up!
(LAUGHING)
Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't
know it was therapy.
Just admit it.
You messed me up.
I admit it.
I messed you up.
Is everything all right
between you and Kathryn?
(PHONE RINGING)
Hello?
Yes, sir.
Calvin, I had my crew
on that yesterday.
Well, I know. I don't
want that to happen either.
(SIGHING) Tomorrow.
Okay, Okay. Calvin,
I'll be right there.
The boss, right?
I gotta go to work.
Yeah, can't do better
than that! Really.
(SQUEAKING)
Yeah. Yeah!
Who's a good girl?
That's my baby.
DAN: Kay?
KAY: How are
Cindy and Sandy?
Well, Cindy's okay,
but Sandy's still nervous.
KAY: Don't quit, Danny.
He can go higher.
That's it!
Okay, girls.
There are my girls.
Thank you. Come on.
Ready and go!
That's it.
What is this? You
ready? I said go!
If those are the best behaviors,
I'd hate to see the worst.
May I help you?
Are you looking
for somebody?
No, I don't think you can. I'm
looking for someone in authority.
Well, I'm Dr. Morgan,
the senior biologist.
Oh.
Really?
Charming. Philip FitzRoyce.
I know you.
I know your work.
We were at that Law of the Sea
Conference together last summer.
Oh yes, that's right.
Helsinki. Save the Whales.
They made a hero out of me.
Yeah, you know what
I never understood?
Why did you ram
that Japanese whaler?
(CHUCKLING) Because he got
in my way, ruined my best shot.
Yeah. I was impressed.
Good. Then perhaps we can have
a drink and some dinner tonight?
Oh, I'm sorry, Mr. FitzRoyce,
but, that's a behavior I just don't do.
(LAUGHING)
Nice spins, Danny. I'll
meet you at the holding tank.
Hey, aqua girl!
Hi, Mike!
Five.
(GRUNTING)
He don't sleep in,
he don't live in.
Tell Shelby Overman for me
he can take a flyin' leap
at a rollin' doughnut on a
gravel driveway, you hear?
Hold it just a second. Didn't
he come home last night?
He didn't show
up here either. No.
I figure he's
home hung over.
I tell you, the man's trash, and I
don't want him around my place!
He's gone.
You take his stuff.
Charlene,
what's goin' on, huh?
Shelby Overman's AWOL again.
Oh, no. I'm sorry.
What, is this
all his stuff?
Yeah. Doesn't figure.
He left his passport and
his... And his credit cards.
Driver's license,
pawn tickets.
I don't think he could have
been planning to go too far.
You don't think
something happened to him?
I mean, wouldn't the
police have called...
No. No, look. He is curled
up, drunk someplace.
And when I find him,
he's in deep trouble.
Don't you worry. We'll let you
know as soon as we hear anything.
Wanna help me out?
Yeah. Take care, Charlene.
Help me look in the lagoon?
You bet.
Hey, I'm mad at that old boy,
but I don't mean him any harm.
You hear me?
I don't mean him any harm!
Down a little more.
Turn it.
Batteries are
fully charged, Mike.
Thank you, Danny.
Thanks, Danny.
Control room, submersible
is now entering the lagoon.
Roger. I can
monitor it from here.
Thank you.
TECHNICIAN: (ON RADIO) Testing,
one, two, three. Can you read me, Kay?
KAY: (ON RADIO) I read you.
Communications fine.
For Charlene's sake,
I sure hope he's all right.
MIKE: (ON RADIO)
There's Cindy or Sandy?
I don't know how
to tell them apart.
KAY: Cindy's a lot larger.
MIKE: Control, this
is Venture One.
We're at 25 feet, headed
for the Spanish Galleon.
I can see you now.
Hi, Mike.
Overman broke divers' rules
last night, out there.
Went down to shackle
the sea gate alone.
If anything happened to him, the ocean
current would have washed him up here,
toward the center
of the lagoon.
KAY: What about
the filtration pipes?
MIKE: No, it's too strong a
current moving the other way.
See, the flow's all
into the lagoon.
There's a million gallons of
fresh salt water every hour.
KAY: You think he could have gotten
trapped in the Spanish Galleon?
MIKE: He could have gotten
caught in the superstructure.
Would have kept him
from floating topside.
KAY: Mike! Oh, God.
For a second I thought...
MIKE: Yeah, yeah- I know it-
We call him Oscar.
You stay here, Kay. I'll go into
the galleon and take a closer look.
KAY: Uh-uh, Mike.
I'm goin' with you.
MIKE: Goddamn dolphins!
What the hell are they doing?
KAY: I don't know. They've been
acting strange for the last two days.
Look at 'em.
KAY: Control,
we're leaving the sub.
We'll be out
of radio contact.
Read you,
Dr. Morgan.
MIKE: Grab your ABS bottles,
Kay- Let's go.
KAY: Okay, sweetie.
(SQUEAKING EXCITEDLY)
(SQUEAKING)
(MUFFLED SCREAMING)
(MUFFLED EXCHANGE)
MIKE: (MUFFLED) Go!
KAY: (MUFFLED) Go!
(SHARK THEME PLAYING)
KAY: Mike! Quick! Mike!
The gate! Get the gate!
Shark!
God!
What's happening?
DAN: Close, damn it! Close!
MIKE: Shit!
Oh, God! Are you okay?
What the hell was that?
Yeah! What is that?
You okay?
My Guv'nor's
the 16th Earl of Haddenfield.
Shake hands with the
first Calvin of SeaWorld.
Enchante. Enchante.
He know French too, huh?
Excuse me, gentlemen.
Mr. Bouchard...
Wait a minute.
We're havin' dinner here.
This better be important.
It is, sir.
(WHISPERING) Mike and Dr. Morgan
were pursued by a renegade shark
that got into our lagoon.
It is important, gentlemen.
Better come with me.
KAY: Believe me, Calvin,
it was a great white.
It was about ten feet long, it was
exhibiting a typical feeding pattern.
On us, Calvin!
The damn thing tried
to feed on us. Exactly.
Now look.
Where is it?
Right here.
Huh?
(WHISTLING) You know, Cal,
this could be a stroke of luck.
If we kill this beastie
on camera,
I can guarantee you
media coverage.
Lure him into a staging area,
and at the precise moment,
slit his belly wide open.
Can you do that?
You try and stop him, mate.
That's how we earn our bread.
(CHUCKLING)
Well, Jack is oversimplifying
matters, as is usual.
But, yeah, I can do that.
KAY: No!
MIKE: No?
What do you mean, no?
Well, I don't know if it's
occurred to any of you all,
but there isn't a great white
alive in captivity anywhere.
Now, we're unique here,
Calvin, you know that.
If any facility can
maintain a white, it's us.
If we could dart him, tranquilize him,
we could get him in a holding tank...
Hold it! This is crazy,
this is nuts.
White sharks are killers.
I know 'em.
My father,
my brother, myself.
They're murderers. No, Kay.
Calvin, they die
magnificently.
(LAUGHING)
That would really be a spectacular
event. No doubt about that, huh?
What are we doing, Calvin,
planning a network special?
Don't you realize that we could
be the first people on the planet
to have a
great white alive.
Not if my Guv'nor
gets it first, miss.
Okay. Say he kills it.
Well, that's it.
It's one shot, over, gone.
But a live great white. Now,
you think about that, Calvin!
Nightly bulletins on the
progress of the killer shark.
Pictures of us nursing it
back to health
and lowering it
into a holding tank.
Now, that's world news!
Think of the lines
at the gate.
Then you miss
the sport of the kill.
Now, wait up, Jack.
Wait up.
PHILIP: Killing is
guaranteed press.
But this other is much,
much more interesting.
DAN: Okay,
this is MS-222.
This is quinaldine, but I had
to guesstimate the dosage.
Kathy?
Right. Thanks, Danny.
All right, we're ready
in Control. You all set?
MIKE: (ON RADIO)
We're ready down here.
(KAY CLEARING THROAT)
Well, with those
TV monitors rolling,
you're gonna have more coverage
than a space launch around here.
Good. Just the
way I like it. Right.
The color of your wet suit's
one hell of a choice.
The shark's gonna love you.
Exactly.
It helps me
get the close-ups.
You're the showman.
(EXHALING)
Honey, you think this
suit's gonna protect you?
Are you kidding?
Have you felt the...
It won't bite through,
but it will yield to pressure.
So she might just get
a little squeeze.
Oh, that's great news. Look,
why do you have to do this?
Why don't you let Her Majesty's
number one son take care of it, huh?
Because it's my job,
remember?
Yeah, but I just don't
want it to be you.
Look, you build all the stuff, I swim
around in it. That was the deal. Right?
Hmm?
I love you, too.
If we get into any trouble, all
we have to do is pull the pin.
What are those?
JACK: Mills bombs.
What?
Mills bombs, sonny.
Grenades. A chap in Her Majesty's
ordnance makes them up for me.
(ON RAADIO) Baby claymores.
Good horizontal dispersion.
Some concussion. A bit rough on
the eardrums, but they do the trick.
Well, not in my water.
Take 'em off.
You tend to your knitting, my
dear, and I shall tend to mine.
MIKE: Hold it.
Hold on a second there.
There's not gonna be
any explosives underwater.
There's acrylic down there,
it's a very fragile environment.
There's no bombs.
PHILIP: Look, Brody, I do
understand. This is insurance...
MIKE: No, I don't think you
understood me here, FitzRoyce!
I spent two years building
this park, and I'm not gonna see
some visiting fireman with a
homemade bomb blow it up
just because he wants
to kill a fish!
Calvin, are you
listening to all this?
No grenades.
For Christ's sake, Guv'nor.
Remember Australia?
Oh, don't worry, Jack.
After all, it's only
a little fish.
Son of a...
The pin has to be pulled.
Right. Get rid
of this stuff.
Everybody aboard here?
Let's get going.
Shove off.
KAY: I need one clean
belly shot.
If I miss on the first pass,
I'm gonna have to reload
and just hope I get him
with the second dart.
PHILIP: This is a good
place to start.
(ENGINES STOPPING)
MIKE: Hit the lights.
Shall we dance?
Yeah, why not? I'm beginning to feel
like King Richard going to the Crusades.
PHILIP: Ready, Jack?
Get the gear.
JACK:
Brown bread, Guv'nor.
You all right?
Good luck.
You know you only
get one shot.
MIKE: Yeah, I know.
I know.
(MIKE EXHALING)
What about Kathryn?
It'll stick in the shark. Hit
her, and it'll go right through.
Just buoy him up,
slow him down, right?
Dorsal fin,
middle of the back.
Seen anything yet?
Yeah, we'll get him
on the monitors.
(KAY GRUNTING)
(KAY SCREAMING)
Quick! Mike,
he's making a run!
Quick, shoot him!
PHILIP: He's getting away!
Damn it!
MIKE: Get out of
the way, Kay!
KAY: Now!
Come on.
Right. There you go.
You did it, baby.
You did it.
DAN: Here's the ladder.
Hold on.
Come on.
Give me your fins.
Let's go!
DAN: Up you go.
You all right?
(GASPS)
Close one back there.
MIKE: Let's get
this stuff off her.
LIZ: Kay, that was great!
What am I,
a bloody porter?
How about a hand
with this hardware?
No, first things
first, Jacko.
Mustn't ignore the ladies.
And don't ignore
the bleedin' help.
MIKE: Looked pretty
hairy down there.
LIZ: You all right, Kay? For
a second, I was so worried.
You sure know how
to scare the hell out of me.
Be sure he's wrapped, okay?
Keep him wet. Let's get him in a tank.
CALVIN: (ON SPEAKER) Film
all right? TV picture looked cloudy.
Calvin. Kathryn's fine,
Philip is fine, Jack is fine.
Dan and Liz are fine.
I am okay too.
But, is the film okay?
It's absolutely
first-rate, Cal.
I think you'll
be very happy.
Is everyone okay?
It did look pretty
dangerous down there.
Yeah, well, it looked pretty
dangerous from down here too, Calvin.
KAY: We may have to work him
all night, keep him moving.
Down, Danny.
Down, down. That's it.
We have to be sure the oxygen
keeps running through his gills.
We don't wanna lose him.
(DOOR OPENING)
Close the door! Whoever
you are, this is off limits.
Liz, uh, get the hose running. I
wanna try aerating him, okay?
Even to me,
the fearless harpoonist?
Nah, you're okay.
Come on in, sailor.
Are you new in town?
Yeah. Came by to get me
a woman and a tattoo.
Wanna see the tattoo?
(CHUCKLING)
Well, I'd rather see the woman,
get a look at the competition.
Sorry, there isn't any other
woman, there isn't any tattoo either.
I'm lonely.
I'm sorry, darlin'.
Damn mammal.
This one's a fish.
A simple, beautiful fish.
Okay.
Mike! Mike! What are
you doing? Are you crazy?
Liz, take a hike.
Okay.
If this is the only way
we can be together,
this is the only way
we can be together.
Welcome aboard, sailor. Get
that hose and hold onto it, okay?
Yeah. Okay.
Open the mouth.
Say hi to your new friend.
You know, this is the first time
you've ever done my work with me.
Yeah, well,
it's a real thrill.
Maybe tomorrow you
can come work with me
and have some real excitement
help me pour foundations.
(SCREAMING)
Get away! Get clear!
Get clear!
Whoa!
Didn't he give
you any signs?
No! One minute
he was dead out,
the next minute
he was wide awake!
No food.
No medication.
It's the only live one in captivity,
guys. Let's keep him that way.
Huh? Don't do anything
that's gonna traumatize him.
(APPLAUSE)
WOMAN: (ON PA) Ahoy, mateys. Welcome
to the opening of the Undersea Kingdom.
The magical mysteries of Jonah
and the Whale, the Coral Forest
and the Sunken
Spanish Galleon.
Gotcha, Guv'nor!
CALVIN: It's a whale with a
brain larger than most folks,
able to earn beaucoup bucks
in a single bound.
Kay and I went down
in the sub,
and we searched
over all this area
before the sharks hit us.
Yeah, but Mike, what if Overman went
down on the other side of the sea gate?
The tide might have
pulled him out,
but we should have had a body
show up somewhere along the coast.
Brody, did you check
the filtration pipe?
No, Calvin. The current's
too strong goin' the other way.
We got a million gallons of sea water
flowing into the lagoon every hour.
The man's irresponsible.
When he turns up, fire him.
Hold it, Calvin.
Hold it.
He's a good man. He just
messes up every once in a while.
I'm gonna hold
you responsible. Hmm?
MAN: (ON PA) And now, she gets to
ski by herself because Patty's the best.
How's it going, Leonard? I
just got today's first print-outs.
Today, our advance sales are
three times ahead of our other parks.
Not unexpected, Leonard.
Where's the great white now?
In the tank room. I want to
put him on display at pool six.
I wanna instruct everyone
to put all that information
on all the welcomes,
rest stops and wrap-ups.
But I thought we were to wait
on Dr. Morgan's word for that.
Look. I run the park, I sell the
tickets and I make the decisions.
Move the fish!
I wanna be able to stand
in line to see it before three.
ALL: Three and down,
and up, and turn.
(WHOOPING)
(UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING)
MAN: (ON PA) And now,
the SeaWorld water ski team
in a dazzling display of
coordination and brilliance.
The Silver Bullets!
All right!
Lookin' good!
There they go!
Yeah! The helicopters!
Hi, Sean.
You were real hot.
I want some time for us alone. You
got a few minutes between shows?
You bet.
Great, Kelly.
Listen.
Ready for some fun?
Fantastic!
Let's ride the bumper boats.
Bumper boats?
WOMAN: Come on, it's fun.
This is the entrance
to the Undersea Kingdom,
an incredible complex
of underwater tunnels
that show you first-hand
the miracles of the deep.
There's no extra charge
for this unique attraction.
Our underwater tunnels are
not only fun, but informative.
Oh, look at that.
ANNOUNCER: Consumed alive in
history, Jonah found out what it was like
to live in the belly of the
ocean's greatest animal.
Our special Jonah and the Whale
showcase is at 11:00, 1:00 and 4:00
in the amphitheater
inside the Undersea Kingdom.
(HISSING)
(WOMEN SCREAMING)
(MAN LAUGHS)
(GIRLS LAUGHING)
MAGNIFIED VOICE:
This is Captain Sink.
Welcome to my cave
of fun and surprises.
GIRLS: Oh, yuck!
MIKE: I sure am gonna
miss these guys.
How 'bout it, Casper?
You wanna take the money and
run to Venezuela with old Mikey?
Quieres un pescado?
You speak Spanish, huh?
(LAUGHING)
I think they're gonna
miss you, too.
Now you and I are gonna have to
have a serious conversation sometime...
About what's really goin' on.
You and me.
I know. I know.
ANNOUNCER: Mike Brody.
Mike Brody. Call your office, please.
See ya later.
(SEALS BARKING)
MAN: (ON PA) SeaWorld,
in honor of opening day...
(CASPER SCREECHING)
Oh, Casper.
What's a girl to do, huh?
Thank you.
MAN: (ON PA) A great white
shark in holding pool number six.
You will be able to view the one
and only great white in captivity.
WOMAN: (ON PA) The great white
shark has roamed the ocean's depths
for millions of years.
A proud animal...
Excuse me. Oh, God!
While alone,
is a predator...
Excuse me!
What is he doing here?
Calvin ordered him moved.
Why didn't he ask me? Why
did he go ahead on his own?
WOMAN: (ON PA) This shark,
a first of its kind to be held...
No, Danny! Danny!
Liz, get a hose ready,
I wanna aerate him now!
Come on, Danny. Get the back.
WOMAN: Just a minute.
Please remain calm.
That's Dr. Morgan and
assistant members of our staff.
Uh, please don't interfere
in any way.
Excuse me.
KAY: Liz! Liz!
Come on, boy.
That's it. Come on.
Turn it, Danny.
Shit!
Come on. Come on!
No. Boy, come on!
Excuse me.
WOMAN: (ON PA) Let me bring
your attention to some other events...
PHILIP: Kathryn.
The seal and otter show
and of course...
Kathryn.
Bad luck.
(SIGHING)
Go ahead.
Photograph it.
Look out!
Kelly. Kelly.
I don't know.
I don't. No. No.
Come on, you'll love it.
It's fun. Trust me. Come on!
What is this thing?
Are you sure?
Are you sure
we should be doing this?
Oh! Oh, God. Can
this hold two people?
Oh. Push. Push.
Oh, my God. Are you
steering this, or am I?
(PEOPLE LAUGHING)
GO! Go! Get away! Get away!
WOMAN: We invite you to enter the magical
world of the deep water Coral Forest
where you may observe the wonders
of the deep without ever getting wet.
The Spanish Galleon plays
host to a myriad of colorful fish
that SeaWorld has assembled
from the different oceans of the world.
Look at all of them!
Oh, yeah!
That looks like a butterfly.
You're right.
(INDISTINCT CHATTER)
MAN: Oh, my God!
Look at that!
(GIRLS SCREAMING)
Look, Kay, I don't think
you want to see this.
Mike, everybody is assuming
that this was a shark attack.
No, I wanna make sure.
Okay. All right.
Did you guys pull him out?
(INDISTINCT RADIO CHATTER)
(RETCHING)
That's Shelby Overman.
Kay, I told...
Miss...
Mike. Ray.
If this was a shark attack,
I've seen it before.
Okay?
Oh, Mike.
Oh, my God!
Let's go find Calvin.
Come on! Come on!
MAN: I'm getting a lot of contradictory
readings from the filtration pumps.
LEONARD: Such as?
High pump rate,
low outflow
and a pressure build-up
on the inboard tunnel valve.
That's number two.
Could be an obstruction.
Well, that's not
my department.
See if you can locate Brody
or Calvin, will you?
CALVIN: Very posh.
Yes, it's quite a display.
Tell me. How do you contain the
sharks in this part of the lagoon?
It's that old shark screen,
that bubble screen.
You know,
sharks don't like that.
It's what they call, uh, marine
segregation. (TELEPHONE RINGING)
Dr. Bouchard. Telephone.
Ah, excuse me, gentlemen.
Get comfortable now.
Here you go, sir.
Bouchard here.
What about the pumps?
Ah, nah, nah, nah.
Don't wait for Brody.
Just, uh, shut down number two
pump and switch over to number one.
Simple as that.
Because it costs too much to
replace and they burn out, that's why!
And tell Brody to get down here to the
Neptune Room on the double, y'hear?
Thank you.
You're welcome.
(SHARK THEME PLAYING)
Well, gentlemen.
Chin-chin.
Oh, cheers.
Cheers.
KAY: There they are.
Calvin, I've got bad news.
Keep your voices down, sit down.
Sit down!
Was it the shark?
It was a shark.
It was a shark
with a bite radius
about a yard across.
Don't be silly. That would indicate
a shark of some 35 feet in length.
You said it exactly.
Our shark still has
all its teeth. Yeah.
That means it was a baby.
Our shark couldn't
have killed Overman.
Its mother did.
You talkin' about
some damn shark's mother?
Calvin, don't you hear
what she's sayin' here?
CALVIN: I'm listening!
Now, if there is
such an animal,
she gave birth way out to sea,
and the baby swam
through the sea gate
that you left open, Brody!
No! Overman was killed
inside the park.
The baby was caught
Its mother is
inside the park.
(ECHOING) She's right there!
(SCREAMING)
WOMAN: How did that
thing get in there?
The animals are in
the lagoon! Ski show!
Control, this is Bouchard.
Now you listen
to me carefully!
I want you to
clear the tunnel,
I want you
to let the people out,
I want you to close
the gate and seal the park!
Seal the park!
I'll be down in a minute.
MAN: Hey! Hey! Watch it!
WOMAN: Who is that guy?
MAN: Watch out!
Hey, bring it over here! Hey!
All right. I've had enough
fun. Let's go in now.
Come on. You're enjoying this.
No. Look, don't you have
to be at work or something?
Tammy's on the pyramid. I don't
have to be back till the second half.
Come on.
Oh.
Gotcha, lovers.
Shit!
God.
Get out! Get out!
Hey, what the?
Hey, what are ya doin'?
Brody!
Get out of the water.
Get out!
Get out of the water, please.
Please, come in from the water.
Out of the water! Come on!
Get out of the water!
Out of the water!
Get out!
Get outta the way!
Shit!
(PHONE RINGING)
MAN: This is
SeaWorld Control.
Uh-huh.
Yes. I got him right here.
ANNOUNCER: All right, boys.
Come on in and take a bow.
I apologize to have you...
No! Get up here!
Get outta the water!
MIKE: Boys. Boys!
Bring the boat in!
Get outta the water!
You're gonna get both
of us fired out here!
Get out! Everybody out!
Gimme the mike!
Hey, Brody! Come back here!
Get outta the water!
Bring it in.
Bring it in!
Bring the boat in!
Get out of the water
right now!
Ready, up! One. Two.
MIKE: Bring that boat in!
Get outta the water right now!
Hey, get me down!
Just get me down!
Get me down!
What are you saying?
There's something back there!
A shark!
Bring your boat in!
(CROWD SCREAMING)
There's a shark!
(AUDIENCE SCREAMING)
(SCREAMING CONTINUING)
GIRLS: One, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
MIKE: Get outta the water!
Oh, my God!
(ALL SCREAMING)
MIKE: Get outta the water!
(SCREAMING CONTINUES)
Get out!
MAN: We're coming!
We're coming!
It's gonna eat us!
They'll die!
Gimme your hand. Come on!
Pull me out!
Hang on!
SEAN: Needs a choke
or something. Pull it.
(BOTH GASP)
SEAN: Hold my hand.
(SCREAMS)
SEAN: Kelly!
Shark!
Kelly!
(SCREAMS)
What the hell is that?
Shit! Hang on!
GIRL: What happened?
She's drowning! She's drowning!
Swim! Swim, kid, swim!
(PEOPLE GASPING)
PHILIP: Call an ambulance.
Quickly. Come on.
Get out of the way!
Give us some
room there, please.
Get a paramedic!
Look out, Mommy!
Kelly!
Did you call an ambulance?
Yeah, the paramedics.
MIKE: Twist that tourniquet
tight and hold it there.
Goddamn shark!
SEAN: I'm here.
You're gonna be okay.
MAN 1: There's still some
injured in the water.
MAN 2: They're bringin'
in the wounded.
MAN 3: The ambulance
is on the way.
Shall I leave the gate open?
Cindy and Sandy are out there.
Shit.
No. They're gonna have to
take care of themselves, Liz.
We can't take our chance
on that big bitch gettin' in.
Hey, you all right?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm fine.
Uh, I'm gonna go with Kelly.
I think you should.
What are you gonna do?
I don't know.
Hello out there.
This is Calvin Bouchard.
May I please
have your kind attention.
Due to technical difficulties,
it has become necessary for us
to temporarily close
the Undersea Kingdom now.
For those of you all still in the
underwater portion of this park,
please follow your guides,
and they will point out the most
convenient and accessible exits.
Where the hell is the nearest
accessible exit? We're underwater!
Is this off?
Uh-huh.
Gimme some lights down there!
Got them right here.
Can't see shit down there!
Get me some medical
attention here, quick!
Okay, ladies and gentlemen,
you all heard the announcement,
so please follow me
in an orderly fashion,
and remember walk, do not run.
Daddy, Daddy!
Look at the fish!
Look!
Holy shit!
(PANICKED SCREAMING)
(SCREAMING)
TECHNICIAN:
Tunnel failure, number six.
It's Jonah and the
Whale- That's it.
Tube integrity has been
compromised.
We've got leakage
and pressure loss.
We have to seal the section
or we'll lose
the whole complex.
Watertight doors.
Hit it. On automatic.
They're all on go status.
Activated. Now!
(PEOPLE SCREAMING)
I need my wallet!
(SCREAMING CONTINUES)
Quiet! Quiet! Please!
I need your attention,
please. Quiet!
Now the water is not going
any higher, so calm down, okay?
It's stopped. It's
stopped, so calm down.
GUIDE: The oxygen that
we have in here is all we have,
so let's not panic, but let's try
to take shallow breaths, okay?
Hey, Mike.
MIKE: Yeah!
This is our last cut. I think
our tunnel patch is ready to go.
Good. Rig the winch
on that work boat up there.
You got it.
How much longer,
sweetie? I don't know.
No?
We're gonna have to nudge
these tunnel sections together.
Then we're gonna slap on a patch
and we're gonna weld the whole thing.
Then we evacuate?
No, then we gotta put
pressure back into the tunnels,
then the watertight doors will
open up, then people go home.
Hey, watch how you're
cutting that thing! It's critical!
Relax. Relax. You're
doing everything you can.
Come on. Come over here.
Listen.
I've been thinking.
Maybe Venezuela can use
some trained whales, huh?
What? Are you serious?
Yeah.
I think this one's on me.
But next year...
I'll follow you anywhere.
Yeah!
I love you!
(CHATTERING)
Ah, Mr. Glass.
Is Mr. Bouchard
going to be here?
Please, please.
I have a statement to make.
Was there an explosion?
What about the fire?
How many people are missing?
Late this afternoon, as a
result of a minor disturbance,
there was a pressure failure in
one of the underwater tunnels
that are a major attraction
here at the park.
We estimate that
30 to 40 people
were in the process
of being evacuated
when the watertight safety doors
temporarily delayed their exit.
We're working right now
to release them
under the safest
possible circumstances.
In addition, seven visitors
were injured in our beach area.
That's all for now.
Give me a break, boys.
What is this we've heard
about a large shark?
I'll let you know as I know
more. A very large shark...
That's all. There is no more.
WOMAN: When will
they get this fixed?
GUIDE: I'm sure they're
working on it.
Stay together to keep warm.
I know you're cold.
Stay together, take shallow breaths
and concentrate on your breathing, okay?
Well, any sign
of mother?
Okay, then.
Where did the animal
hide the first time?
Uh...
Filtration pipe.
Opposite side of the lagoon.
Brody, is there an access
hatch, a backwash gate?
Heavy grill work.
Keeps the pumps clear when
we back-flush that system.
Why? What do you want to do?
Get that thing back in?
He's a bright lad.
Yes. Jack and I are going
to lure him back into the pipe,
close the gates and then
dispose of him at our leisure.
Meanwhile, you can weld
your tunnel patch
and then Calvin can
evacuate the civilians.
What if she doesn't
want to go back in?
Oh, I think we can pretty much
guarantee she'll want to go back in.
Don't you, Jack?
Sure.
Just how are you
going to guarantee that?
Live bait.
MAN: We're ready to move
out over the tunnel now.
MIKE: Let's go.
I'll be in the
Control Room.
I'll go with you.
MAN: Give me that.
Let me stow it over here.
No, I got it.
TECHNICIAN: Yeah,
we're on top of it.
Okay. Thanks.
Now, where's
that damn fish?
There. I've got him.
Sorry, it's just the dolphins.
Babies, stay out
of it, please.
And I've rigged
a lifeline.
Just let the pumps push you out and
use the rope to pull yourself back in.
Right.
And why don't
I do all the filming?
I want both cameras. We need
the coverage. Come on, Jack!
This isn't a picnic.
This film is a bloody
retirement annuity.
I'd feel better if you
did just the one thing.
What's the matter?
Getting cold feet?
Okay, Bob. Hold it
about right there.
We're right over the tunnel.
Okay, we're all set down here.
MIKE: Tell FitzRoyce
we're in position.
FitzRoyce, you can go now.
They're testing the
lifeline to see if it's secure.
CALVIN: They're spreadin' some
chum. You know, fish oil and blood.
Then Jack's gonna make
some metallic sounds
to attract her right down
into that filtration pipe.
Start the pumps.
You got it.
(METAL CLANGING)
(SHARK THEME PLAYING)
TECHNICIAN: It's in!
CALVIN: He's got it!
All right. It's locked.
It's safe, Brody.
Go for it.
Okay, let's go.
(MUFFLED SCREAMING)
TECHNICIAN: This is Control.
Is that tunnel patch in place?
Easy.
Let me help you
with that, Dr. Morgan.
Got it!
Now weld the
son-of-a-bitch...
Kathryn,
what are you doin'?
I'm going down there.
You crazy?
He needs eyes in the
back of his head, Calvin.
Thanks, Fred.
All right.
Watch the tanks.
Okay.
Here are your fins.
Thanks.
Be careful down
there now.
(HINGES CREAKING)
(SIGHING)
You all right?
Where's Mr. FitzRoyce?
I have no idea.
MAN: What's goin' on?
Guv'nor!
There's no other way out?
You don't understand.
This is it!
Have you looked?
He didn't come up.
Guv'nor, you bloody bastard.
Answer me!
We'll suffocate the bitch.
Shut down the pumps.
Are you sure?
Why don't we blow it up?
Listen, nephew.
That's a $2.5 million turbine that's not
going up in smoke because of some damn fish!
Now shut the pumps down!
(MECHANICAL WHIRRING)
What's happened?
MAN: They've shut
the pumps off.
(SIGHING) That's all she needs.
The gates can't hold much longer.
(SOBBING) Philip, pull
the pin! Pull the pin, Philip.
(METALLIC CLANKING ON MONITOR)
(CLANKING)
(CLANKING CONTINUING)
WOMAN: Look at that!
WOMAN: Jesus!
FRED: Oh, my God!
We gotta warn 'em.
We gotta tell 'em!
Get 'em up!
It's coming back.
Get 'em up quick!
Come on! Hurry up!
Come on!
Get 'em up!
Come on, Mike.
Get out of there!
Come on, Mike!
CALVIN: Get 'em up!
(SHARK THEME PLAYING)
(MUFFLED) Come on!
(SQUEAKING)
(MUFFLED) Pull the door!
(GASPING)
How the hell
did it get loose?
Open the hatch!
FRED: Come on up,
Mike. I gotcha.
Are you all right?
Do we have pressure
in those tunnels yet?
Affirmative. Then open up the
bulkheads, get those people out of there.
Done.
Feel the air!
Can you feel the air?
The water's going down.
The water's going down!
Try to be calm.
Don't rush to the door.
We're saved!
(ALL CHEERING)
(SHARK THEME PLAYING)
(SCREAMING)
(MUFFLED YELLING)
(CRUNCHING)
Oh! We did it!
The others, Mike.
What about the others?
Calvin made it. Lisa.
Mike. Mike! The dolphins!
KAY: Cindy!
MIKE: Cindy!
KAY: Sandy!
Come on, girls! Cindy!
Cindy!
Oh, good girl. Sandy!
(SQUEAKING)
Sandy, come on, baby.
Sandy, where are you?
MIKE: Sandy!
I hope she made it.
Cindy, stay.
Sandy.
(SQUEAKING)
Sandy!
All right!